[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't have any doubt
ladies and gentlemen making the
transatlantic partnership
work means reinvigorating
ties among key countries in europe
and in north america i could not be more
excited today
to welcome three very special guests
virtually of course to munich today
thank you so much for joining us
a very very warm welcome
good morning to washington dc
hello nach berlin
[Music]
we are so excited to have you here
together
and have you talk about a new
transatlantic agenda
and i'm sure you are aware that boris
johnson
will join this program a little later he
was still busy with wrapping up
the g7 meeting in which you all
participated earlier
so now as our first
speaker in this program it is my
privilege
to welcome the 46th president
of the united states president joe biden
has truly been a loyal and
long-term friend of the munich security
conference
[Music]
in 2019
mr president you said
in this very place in this very hall
we will be back mr president
thank you for keeping that promise we
welcome you
back to the stage and you have thank you
mr ambassador it's great to be with
angela and emmanuel
we just mentioned part of from
washington
together
for decades as you pointed out i
participated in the special security
conference
for decades senator joining my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
as the u.s assembly of georgia fans
of the aisle to every time the vice
president of the transatlantic
bargaining the first
three times including delivering the
first administration
international foreign policy address of
the obama
two years ago you pointed out in the
first months last spoken unity
two years ago as you pointed out i was a
professor i last spoke
to the first i was a private citizen i
said at that time
she is i'm sending a clear message from
transatlantic alliance america's back
is back we are not looking at the
atlantic alliance we are looking
forward together and we are not looking
at this
we are looking inside this is a strong
fountain down to this
the global dynamics has shifted and as
even as vice president crises demand our
global dynamics have shifted cannot
focus only on the crisis
the threat can i focus only on global
challenges among the countries
we continue to support peace the goal of
the united states is
fully committed free and nato alliance
the united states system
is growing investigative military
capabilities and i welcome
our growing investment
that is our attack on one shakable
attack on all
and the only time article five has been
involved
was after the united states the only
time article five was nine
eleven it was after you joined us
strongly bring an end to this that is
closing it's underway
20 the end of this war we remain
committed to ensuring that afghanistan
never again
provides a base we remain committed to
afghanistan never against the base
[Music]
while the united states is undergoing
united
[Music]
cap able to be based by the previous
administration and the number of
forces i know people passed basis
strained and tested
i know islamic relations you know the
past few years minus test is determined
islamic relations determined to
re-engage the united states is
determined consult with you
determine earn back our position of
trusted leadership to consult with you
earlier today turn back our position of
trusting i participated in the first
meeting earlier today
the global economic crisis and the
accelerated climate goals
so much else core strategic process
achieving these goals
enduring and the united states must
renew american challenges from a
position advantage and strength
so that we can meet that is better
foundation reclaiming our buildings
our economic foundations lifting up our
value in our place and internationally
speaking now to defend them around
our values at home modernizing our
military
around our world leading with diplomas
modernizing our military
vitalizing america's network of
alliances
revitalizing america's network of
alliances and partnerships that have
made
the world safer for our fellow
democracies
are going to join us in this video i
hope our fellow partnerships
are going to happen growing through the
years our partnership rooted in
absorbed and grown
[Music]
time very straightforward you know that
i speak my mind
in the midst of a fight it may be very
straightforward with you all about the
future
we are in the midst of a fundamental
debate we're adding inflation about the
future and direction
of those who argue we're active for all
the
and those who understand that democracy
is essentially
going to exist ultimately
historians are going to examine and
write about this i believe that
every as an inflection point as i said
that democracy and i believe
every ounce of my being we must
demonstrate
and must still deliver for our people we
must demonstrate that democracy can
still
deliver
that and my foreign are galvanizing
missions you have to defend it
democracy doesn't happen by accident
strengthen it we need to defend it
we have to strengthen it in a relic of
history
we have to prove it's the single our
i know we'll meet every challenge and
outpace every challenger
long term strategic company no we must
compare together
for long term strategic competition with
china
work together to secure the people how
the united states europe and asia values
that's what i welcome that's what i
believe in the global system and that's
what i welcome the united states
together because i believe
in the global system in new york and
they work so hard
to build over their allies and the
indo-pacific work so hard to build over
the right side
of the future but we do so we have to be
clear on race
for the few historic investments and
partners do so we have to be clear-eyed
investments and partnerships protect for
space for innovation right to protect
intellectual property
we have to protect this base for
innovation throughout the intellectual
property
of ideas creating genetic societies it
thrives with the freedom
to ensure these and open the benefits of
growth are shared broadly and expect to
ensure
we have to push back against the chinese
government economic producers and
coercions
that undercut every foundations
everyone us and european council played
by the same required the public this
publicly usually european company is
struck two required republicans
publicly described by rural government
artificial intelligence
values pushing back against those
possible for us to comment
and normalize pushing back against those
who would
monopolize oh this is also uh repression
is also how
we're going to be able to this is also
from russia this is also how
it attacks our democracies and
weaponizes russia to try to undermine
kremlin attacks our democracies and
weaponizes russian leaders
system of government more corrupt
russian laws want people to think that
our system is cr
to weaken your underlying
negotiate with the strong that's why
that's why standing up for the
sovereignty
and territories of ukraine that's why
standing up for this
vital concern for territorial ukraine
that's why vital concerns dress up in
the united states
across europe and the world has become
the challenges protected
may be different than the ones with
china the challenges there's russia is
real
maybe different than the ones not about
east against what they're just as real
it's not about it's not about coming
east against west we want a future we're
all nations not about
we want to confront really determine
their own you want a future we're all
nations out of a threat of violence
records really determine their own path
we cannot
validate violence records reflective
opposition you cannot
return to the reflective competition
must not lock
cooperation on issues that affect us
competition must not lock example
cooperation on issues we must cooperate
if we're going to defeat copenhagen
everywhere
we must cooperate our first presidential
map in 1999 and focused on
is
simultaneously work strengthen global
health finally
financing early warning strengthen
global health suspect and respond and
create
early warning because they will protect
and respond
to the future biological threats
strengthen the reform
health organization we have to work
together we need a strengthened system
focused on biological threats that can
move quickly u.n systems
on biological threats similarly quickly
we can no longer delay or deliver a bare
minimum
to address can no longer delay this or
do the bare minimum
we have to rapidly confidence to
aggressively build our goals
and the whole other academicians for
meeting our goals that's why
as president meeting the jewish parish
agreement
that's why as of today
once again a party and as of today the
united states
is officially once again a party on
earth day to the paris agreement i will
host the leaders summit
to help drive a more ambitious account i
will host the leadership
of the top emitters drive a more
ambitious climate action here in the
united states
including i am a great climate action
here grateful for
continued leadership on climate issues i
am grateful for the last four years
for europe's continued leadership on
climate change to invest in the last
technological innovations that are going
to empower
our clean investors technology build a
clean energy solution clean energy
future global markets enable us to build
a clean energy threat of nuclear
proliferation
to global markets also continues to
require a threat of nuclear
proliferation
diplomacy cooperation also continues to
require
transparency communication to minimize
the risk of strategic misunderstandings
mistakes communication to minimize
that's why the united states
is understanding our mistakes
with the p5 plus one must also address
the range of stabilizing activities
across the middle east
we must also work in close cooperation
with our europeans
and other partners as we perceive the
work in close cooperation we also work
together
and other parties
material to prevent terrorist groups
from acquiring challenges europe and the
united states must
take on together the range broadcast
challenges europe and the united
thoughts on the way forward you cannot
allow self-help
to hinder our ability to engage each
other we cannot allow
self-doubt to hinder our ability to
engage the last four years
or have been hard larger world but
europe in the last four years
[Music]
to security of europe and the united
states to meet any challenge i know we
can to secure
our futures before i guess yesterday yes
we have just a seven month three yes
yesterday
million mile journey after a seven month
nassar 300
million miles per surveillance rover on
nasa
successfully landed it's on a mission
first rover on mars
with elements contributed by
contributing partners
with
over the next few years samples
envisioned as a joint
anything
i want you to know the united states we
have everything we need you will do our
part
i want you to know we'll fight for our
shared values
we'll stand we'll meet the challenges
we'll fight for our shared values
we'll meet the challenges of this new
moment let's get together
americans demonstrate to our great great
grandchildren when they read them and
demonstrate
that democracy our great great
grandmother when they read about us
democracy functions democracy together
democracy there's nothing democracy
functions and works and together so
let's get working
there's nothing thank you all very can't
do so let's get working
thank you all very much
thank you folks governor's request for a
major disaster declaration
yes i had a chance to speak with the
governor again
uh last night thank you and uh
i asked him whether uh he was about to
and let me ask for another i look
forward to a time effort
emergency
discussion that's possible to get done
with federal government help fema
is already there and providing support
uh generators diesel fuel water blankets
and other
uh supplies but i've directed
health and human services hhs housing
and urban development u.s department of
agriculture
the department of defense to identify
other resources
other resources that can provide and
address
the growing needs of the folks in in
in texas and as a little bit
along the lines i was just talking about
when any state
as i said when i ran uh
i'm going to be a president for all
america
all right there's no red or blue it's
all about
commitment to the american people make
to one another and so we're going to
sign that declaration once it's in front
of me and god willing it will bring a
lot of relief to a lot of texans and so
thank you all so very
[Music]
plans to visit much
it depends the answer is yes
the question is i had planned on being
in texas the middle of next week but
what i don't want to be is a burden
when the president lands in any
city in america it creates uh um
uh there's a it has a long tail
and they're working like the devil to
take care of their folks
if in fact it's concluded that i can do
without creating a burden for the folks
on the ground while they're dealing with
this crisis
i plan on going but i'll we'll know that
we'll make that decision probably
beginning
next week okay thank you